so don't use the new year resolutions
concept but I'm gonna teach this to you
right now and that's the concept of D I
G if you want 2019 to be the year that
you really want to be here is here so
here's the secret of making it a great
year
in 2019 start valuing the right
relationships like you never have before
daily routine so to the decor price will
imply that late 2019 your best year ever
also want to know what Dan la gare de
Mel Robbins and others have to say about
building unstoppable confidence check my
250 for confidence series where every
day for the next 250 4 days I will send
you a morning video for free to help you
build your confidence don't join us in
the description below after you practice
Marshall you develop this natural self
confidence not cockiness but you develop
this natural self-confidence if you
didn't give a [ __ ] what anybody else
thought what's the thing you would love
to be doing with your life the reason
people don't put themselves in a
position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much
[Music]
okay let's see rule number one use the
tig concept with deadlock let's say this
year and you say you know what Dan I
have a certain financial goal an income
goal maybe you want to make $50,000
$100,000 at you two hundred thousand
dollars a year
half a million dollars are you all you
know what you say this is a year I'm
going to make a million dollars a year
whatever you go is let's take simple
math a hundred thousand dollars a year
let's say let's make it even simple and
then 20k distich 10k a month ten
thousand dollars a month that's your
goal so don't use the new year
resolutions concept here's the concept I
talked about in my book if you money you
can go get the book from Amazon but
we're gonna teach this to you right now
and that's the concept of D I G d IG it
stands for daily income goal daily
income goal so let's say you take 10,000
a month and you break it down you
divided by 30 days each day you got to
make about 340 somewhat dollars let's
just run it up 350 bucks
that's your the IG daily income goal
three hundred and fifty dollars that you
need to make every single day if you
want to hear ten thousand dollars a
month now I want you to think about this
when you get in the morning the first
thing that comes to your mind the first
question you have to ask yourself is
what am i doing today there will make me
three hundred and fifty dollars today
what do I need to do what do I need to
focus on what what are my objectives am
i hitting my daily income goal what does
massive action looked like what would
Dan Locke do ask yourself those
questions guess what if you're not
hitting your daily income goal you are
not hitting your weekly income goal
you're not hitting your income goal
you're not hitting your monthly income
go if you're not hitting a monthly
income goal you're not hitting your
yearly income goal you don't need to
wait till December and you look at a
calendar and say oh you know what I
screwed up I am way behind
are nowhere near making $100,000 what is
going on I know exactly what's going on
you are not hitting your daily income
goal you can look at your progress every
single day what am i doing today to hit
my daily income go oh well I'm kind of
done doing anything today well then
don't blame and don't [ __ ] when you're
hitting you go oh well you know what
today I'm excited I'm fired up I've hit
my income goal you know what not just I
exceeded my daily income goal instead of
thirty and fifty bucks a day I hit five
in a buck today good for you a good job
that means you have 250 bucks buffer
extra that's good it doesn't mean
tomorrow you're like all slack off and
slow down it means okay
I've exceeded that today yes there are
some days maybe you hit it there's some
days you don't you gotta average it out
tomorrow you get back into it welcome
the morning what am i doing today what
am I gonna do today to hit that 250
bucks and what do I need to do every
single day to accomplish my daily income
goal the concept of the eye G isn't it
much more powerful than some new year
resolutions rule number two
serve every day with John Maxwell if you
want 2019 to be the year that you really
want to be here is here so here's the
secret of making it a great year every
day serve someone every day every day
add value to people every day serve one
every day live the intentional life of
doing for others sometimes what they
cannot do for themselves and if you will
put people first and add value to them
and serve them it becomes absolutely
amazing what you and I are going to have
and achieve how we're gonna help people
and in return how it comes back to us
Benjamin Franklin said this no one is
useless in this world who lightens the
burden of someone else if you're if
you're helping someone else lift a load
in your life you become a very useful
person Mahatma Gandhi said that the best
way to find yourself is to lose yourself
in the service of others but perhaps on
this kind of a theme my favorite quote
is from Alberts
right sir who said I don't know what
your destiny will be but one thing I do
know the only ones among you who will be
really happy are those who have sought
and found how to serve but he's right on
the happiest people are not always the
most successful people but they're the
ones who serve the best I I met a lot of
unhappy successful people haven't you
but I've never met never met an unhappy
person that gave their life of serving
and giving and adding value to other
people Martin Luther King jr. said
everybody can be great because everybody
can serve in about 27 I heard Zig Ziglar
say who became a great friend of mine
Zig said if you will help people get
what they want then you'll receive
everything that you need in life and
when I heard that I thought oh why I've
got this turned around I need to focus
on people I need to put others first and
if I help them then all the stuff that
I'm going to need I'm going to get as a
return one of the reasons why living an
intentional life is so important is we
if we are not intentional we will be
selfish you know we got to work at this
we've got a wiff 2019 is gonna be
incredible year you're gonna have to
look at the year and say to yourself
what can I do to add value to people
instead of what our people want to do
that value to me what can I do to serve
people instead of I wonder who in this
next year is going to serve me we're
gonna have to do a complete mind shift
in that whole process service / status
and so if 2019 is going to be the year
that we really want to make it I want to
share with you right now five things I
do every day and I want you to do them
every day and this year and I will
promise you I will promise you your life
is about two incredibly change number
one everyday I found
you people and that's the foundation of
everything we're talking about if I
don't value people
I'll never add value to them I'll
manipulate him I'll do all kind of bad
things but it all begins with valuing
people that make sense to you server to
add value people by the way that's Jesus
like that's what Jesus what if you say
it won't be christ-like just value
people every day I value people number
two every day I think of ways to add
value to people in other words I look at
my schedule in the morning I'll say
where I'm going to go who I'm gonna see
perhaps and I'll say okay what can I do
to add value to those people I think of
ways that value people number three
every day I look for ways dad valued
people so that when I'm with you so when
I'm with you I'm looking for something
what could I do to fit right in right
now what can I do for them would add
value to so every day I value people
think of what is that value people look
for is that value people number for
every day I do things that values people
every day in fact at the end of the day
the last thing I do every evening is I
do a 10-minute inventory of my day and
one of the questions I ask is who did I
add value to today who did I serve today
okay every day every day
I value people think of what's that
value people look for ways that value
people do things that add value to
people and number five I encourage
others to add value to people I do those
five things every day and I'm just
telling you if you'll just do those five
things every day in 2019 and every one
of you can do that if you'll just do
those if you'll just do this
those five things every day 2019 will be
unbelievable to you rule number three
make decisions that energize you with
Mel Robbins I believe that passion is
another word for energy that's it
what do you have energy for what
energizes you and that we naturally have
a tremendous amount of body wisdom about
that and that every one of us has an
internal fuel tank that is either empty
or full and if you're empty you feel
depleted if you're full you feel
energized and so if you simply are in
any situation I mean any situation and
you pay attention within five seconds to
does this person energize me do they
deplete me where are they in the scale
you just gain some tremendous wisdom and
you the simple way to start to figure
out who you are and what you want is
start aligning yourself with more things
that energize you
so situationally if you're lying in bed
and the snooze alarm goes or the alarm
goes off and you feel depleted and you
start reaching for the snooze button
that's a really big sign that you need
to get out of bed now being depleted
versus energized has nothing to do with
whether or not things are hard or easy
it has to do with what naturally
actually either expands you or shrinks
you and so if you look at your client
list and measure it depleted versus
energized what shrinks versus expands me
you have the actual map and when you
start to find the courage to make
decisions that energize you and that
expand you whether they're scary or not
that's when everything changes and so
that's how I actually make business
decisions is this I don't even like the
money conversation comes second it's
does this deplete or energize me and if
it depletes me how do you move it in
that direction or how do I stay sane oh
if it energizes me how do I do more
because if you are energized or expanded
by something you will do it for no money
you will do it happily
and you will suddenly wake up and say oh
my gosh like my heart I'm pursuing my
passion how did that happen
before start valuing the right
relationships with Patrick Beatty
the fourth habit is directed to those of
you that are so determined to win that
you look at everybody in your life as
somebody has a piece on the chessboard
this person can help me do this and that
person can help me do this and this
person is gonna help me advance to the
other area and what happens when you
look at everybody like that that they're
disposable there's one thing that goes
away the value of relationships goes
away I just turned 40 years old and I
can tell you one thing at 40 that's
different than 30 that's different than
20 is relationships let me explain it
maybe from a different angle think about
it this way who are the five
relationships that you currently have in
your life business personal life fiber
relationships that you currently have
right now in your life that you cannot
lose and you want to have 10 20 30 40
years from now who are those five
relationships think about those names
write them down what are you doing to
water those relationships very similar
to water and good plant what are you
doing to watering those relationships to
make sure they win just as much as you
win so 10 20 30 years from now those
relationships are still in your life
because the idea of wanting to do
something big in 2019 and kick-off the
next 5 10 20 years as a massive massive
run of your life you're not gonna be
able to do it with a lot of solid
relationships so in 2019 start valuing
the right relationships like you never
have before stop overthinking things
with Gary Vaynerchuk if the Internet is
where people's attention is you got
music posted on Instagram now you're
behind doors started everybody thinks
you need a million followers what if
you're one follower is you it's not
about how many it's who and what can
they do if you got SoundCloud and
Spotify and Instagram and YouTube guys T
grizzly comes out of jail after five
four and a half years yeah from being
up for a half decade to putting out one
video and a song if you've got talent
this is about talent sure and all of a
sudden 72 hours later twenty-one Savage
is DMing you so if you've got flames and
you've got bars and you're so great
put it out but what's happening is
people are insecure of course people are
overthinking people are artists trying
to make it perfect it's ego free with
Grant Cardone and how to take the price
that I think that is enjoyed but before
that is the three-point landing
questions time just watching another
video - taking action in your life or
business - feeling bold the your answers
in the comments below here we go
question number one what do you need to
stop overthinking number two what
decision can you make right now that
will energize you and number three what
can you do to serve today when you start
getting out oh god this is stupid
these cars that you're seeing people buy
I think 50 cent got six seven two
Christmases now I got my wife of
Cullinan and I got myself this this is
ridiculous you don't need to go out and
buy these cars okay this is without a
doubt complete waste of money and unlike
unlike some of the people that are out
buying because there's a lot of young
kids right now thinking oh I'm gonna go
buy a Lambo I'm gonna get a Ferrari I'm
gonna go go buy me a rose I've watched a
twenty four-year-old kid by Rolls Royce
I'm like man I don't even look good on
you even if you can't afford what you
see right here is completely ridiculous
but years 35 years of hard work not just
hard work but making good decisions and
putting the money away putting the money
away and not doing this kind of stuff
put all this stuff off don't do this
right now okay pay the price right now
work hard get great at your job get
great at whatever you do so good that
people are like man you're the best well
who are you what do you want they start
asking questions about wow what makes
you so unique then you're gonna start
getting paid more there's no way on this
planet that if people don't if people
start talking about how exceptional you
are you will get paid more at some point
when you do take that money and invest
it in something where you can't lose it
where it pays you every month and one
day in the future it'll be worth more
than it is today do that for years it
might take 10 years 15 years 20 years
I'm just starting to enjoy my life a lot
of hard work man
if you want more motivation for 2019
check out the video we did on Erika
Thomas the link is right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you that not
because I'm comparing myself to them but
ain't nobody like me I am God I am where
I want to be he was like you stop being
a victim